thank you some breaking news this
morning metro police responding to a
homicide in downtown las vegas this is
in the area of first and palm lane it's
where we find bianca holman joining us
live to tell us a bit more bianca
good morning well that yellow tape in
the officer that was here on patrol is
gone now there was also a red vehicle
you may remember in front of this white
house that has been towed away
and again just about a few moments ago
that that's when that all happened but
officers were out here taking pictures
of this yellow home they were taking
pictures of that red
vehicle that was in front of the house
and so this is just east of main street
just to kind of give you some
perspective on where we are and this is
all in relation to a homicide
investigation that happened overnight
early this morning and so details are
still very limited
they have opened this part of biltmore
back up you can see again there was
yellow tape here
just about 15 minutes ago it has since
reopened and also down on first and palm
that area is now open in this small
neighborhood in downtown las vegas so as
we learn more about this investigation
that has been ongoing we will keep
everyone updated online and on air
bianca holmen live local now
they